[Musique]
est ce que vous vous souvenez quand nous
étions enfants les trois questions que
nous poser les adultes à chaque réunion
de famille
alors qu'est ce que tu voudras faire
plus tard
bon je suis pas trop
j'aime bien les licornes j'aime bien me
déguiser
mannequin pour licorne
de cette question est est ce que tu as
un amoureux un amoureux
moi j'ai dix ans alors oui j'aimerais
bien une amoureuse en fait
troisième question
comment ça se passe à l'école s la
troisième question moi c'était ma
préférée
pourquoi parce que quand papy mamie me
demander comment ça se passe à l'école
je pouvais dire fièrement qui sut
première de la classe j'ai les
meilleures notes
et du coup sam assurer une certaine
tranquillité une certaine tranquillité
je savais pas trop pourquoi je faisais
ça mais ça les rangs des heureux alors
je continue
dans ma classe par contre c'était pas la
même limonade il y avait des élèves on
voyait très bien qui était classé un peu
en dessous qui avait de mauvaises notes
et je voyais bien qu à chaque fois qu on
leur rendait leur copie il était
malheureux
mon frère faisait partie de ces élèves
là
et tous les soirs devant les devoirs ça
pleurait ça pleurait
moi j'ai gardé ça en tête mais j'ai
continué toujours avec facilité donc des
études du coup quand on réussit on
continue longtemps plusieurs cursus
universitaire puis comme l'école ça
marche on passe aux concours de
recrutement de professeurs les écoles en
devient enseignant on passe de l'autre
côté de la barrière
hélas dès les premiers jours je retrouve
la différence les enfants comme moi qui
réussissent quand deux d'excellentes
notes puis les enfants comme mon frère
quand de mauvaises notes est allé max
max petit élèves que j'ai eu à la
première année d'enseignement
max c'est un élève qui était fabuleux
cet élève là il était capable d'écouter
la leçon avec un bouquin sur les genoux
de répondre aux copains pendant qu'ils
se questionner tous ensemble et puis de
construire suspendu avec une règle gomme
et un marshmallow
pas besoin d'être enseignant pour voir
qu'il était très très très intelligent
pourtant la maîtresse de l'année d'être
précédente m'avait dit attention ligne
tu vas voir cet enfant ne veut plus
écrire il ne veux plus toucher un stylo
c'est un gros gros problème c'est vrai
c'était un exercice où il se sentait
très très mal donc j'ai eu beau aller
vers ce qu'il aimait faire différemment
mais ça ne fonctionnait pas je voyais
que ça faisait longtemps longtemps
longtemps que cette activité le mets tes
mains dans le mal donc j'ai reçu les
parents plusieurs fois je les ai reçus
et les parents dans leur tête c'était
non non non non on en ligne ton
intuition nous savons que c'est un
enfant intelligent c'est ok mais non il
doit travailler plus nous on le fait
travailler le soir on le fait travailler
le week end nous le faisons travailler
pendant les vacances il faut qu'il y
arrive tu te rends compte silva
l'université qui ne sait pas prendre de
notes
à 10 ans - dans ma tête je me disais
pauvres est
est-ce qu'il va aller à l'université on
n'en sait rien pour l'instant
donc je les ai reçu plusieurs fois et
puis pour qu'ils m'écoutent ou qu'ils
essayent un peu de changer je suis allé
marc mais des neurosciences et des
textes des littératures donc je leur ai
porté des résultats sur les études sur
le cerveau et je leur ai dit voilà
qu'est ce que ça nous montre ça nous dit
que le cerveau d'un enfant en
développement s'il est soumis au stress
à répétition c'est contreproductif il
apprend moins bien
et à partir de ce constat là moi j'avais
des preuves scientifiques
avec les parents on a mis en place des
choses différentes on s'est dit on
bannit toute les situations où il est
mal à l'aise et on le laissera revenir
quand son estime sera renforcée
et aussi en met de côté tous les moments
de comparaison avec la petite soeur la
petite soeur elle caresse icr ici c'est
vraiment vraiment bien à l'école
donc on a fait ça on a fait ça il ya eu
beaucoup d'autres rendez vous évidemment
parce que ben quand on est parent c'est
pas facile d'entendre de changer la
demande de changer de la pardonne autre
adulte et puis de toute manière ce n'est
pas facile de changer tout court surtout
quand on a toujours fait comme ça
et moi
j'allais mettre rapidement le doigt
dessus mon fils est rentré à l'école eh
oui et dès les premiers jours ça a été
maintenant mais pourquoi tu me fais ça
j'ai pas envie moi de faire ça les
fiches la maîtresse me demande
alors quand on est enseignant
entendre ça de la part de son enfant ça
nous met dans une situation un peu
de stabilisante on va dire bon et donc
moi aussi j'ai eu droit à ce fameux
rendez vous la convocation avec la
maîtresse est la maîtresse a le reçoit
et elle me dit line c'est la catastrophe
robin ne veux pas écrire il ne veut pas
produire toutes les fiches que je lui
demande
je pense qu'il va être en échec scolaire
dans ma tête je rigole un peu je me dis
ça à la maîtresse aller sous les effets
de la colère sont allés sous les effets
de l'alcool
bon
ok je dis rien
je prends mon fils je monte dans la
voiture et puis là la boule au ventre
un peu comme maintenant d'ailleurs la
boule au ventre le stress
et puis je revois la tête de mon frère
en train de pleurer dans ses devoirs
je revois max qui regardaient les yeux
de ses parents voyant qu'ils étaient
stressés et je revois tous mes camarades
du collège à qui on mettait le bureau
face à la fenêtre parce que il ne
comprenait pas ce qui se passait au
tableau
je me suis dit là non c'est pas possible
il faut pas que ça se passe comme ça
pour mon fils et pourtant j'étais
stressé et j'arrivais pas à lâcher ya
rien à faire je suis enseignante mon
fils aussi il faut que ça se passe bien
à l'école
bizarrement j'arrivais à me concentrer
sur le besoin des élèves a demandé aux
parents de mettre leurs attentes de côté
j'étais incapable de le faire pour mon
fils je savais ce qu'il fallait faire je
savais le faire
je ne le faisais pas
waouh j'ai commencé à me demander ce qui
se passait en moi j'ai commencé à me
demander quel sens je donnais mon métier
quelle était ma place en tant que
parents dans l'éducation de mon enfant
est là là ça devenait trop compliqué
pour moi je devenais folle presque et je
me suis dit stop on arrête tout on
arrête tout faut changer ok on change
tout qu'est ce que je pouvais faire
et bien moi comme d'habitude je suis
allé dans les bouquins et là donc j'ai
lu sur la liberté la liberté d'apprendre
j'ai lu sur le and cooling j'ai lu sur
les écoles démocratique et je lui ai
rencontré thierry pardo et la piraterie
éducative cette trêve et
je me suis dit ligne ça fait 35 ans que
tu es à l'école peut-être qu'il est un
de ceux des scolarisés
je me suis dit je vais me mettre en
pause avec mes élèves et mon enfant je
veux arrêter de tout contrôler
ok bon c'est pas facile mais je les fais
donc je les ai observés sans vouloir
trop contrôler ce qu'ils faisaient et
qu'est ce que j'ai vu alors d'abord j'ai
vu des enfants qui n'ont absolument rien
à faire de ce qu'ils vont faire plus
tard comme métier ça c'est sûr tout au
plus ils se demandent ce qu'ils vont
manger à midi ou avec qui vont jouer
c'est tout mais par contre ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on a des enfants qui
construisent qui déconstruisent il
expérimente il tâtonne ils se trompent
ils réessaye il se trompe il persévère
ils vont vers ceux qu'ils aiment
ils font des choix se construisent une
identité
et quand on est professionnel de
l'éducation et qu'on connaît les
programmes parker et bien ça va bien au
delà de ce qui est attendu un vrai
alors par contre c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué parce que on ne contrôle
rien
ouais ce n'est plus notre cadre de
travail ça devient le leur et ils
prennent
l'espace
et nous ne contrôlons à rien on doit
travailler davantage
non c'est pas vrai on travaille pas
davantage c'est eux qui travaillent
c'est eux qui travaillent nous nous
sommes seulement là pour faciliter leur
apprentissage
notre responsabilité d'adulte c'est de
leur faire confiance dans leur choix de
les écouter
d'installer un cadre sécurisant pour que
tout se passe et le reste reviendra ça
viendra
si on reprend des nouvelles de mon petit
élève max moi je pensais qu'il allait
devenir architecte
ben non ses parents à accepter qu'ils
quittent l'école à 16 ans et il s'est
inscrit dans une école de cirque il a
fabriqué une paire d'échasses à ressort
et il a monté son propre spectacle qu'il
a produit dans plusieurs pays du monde
je pense qu'il est heureux
voilà ses parents lui ont donné cet
espace il a pu aller vers ce qui les met
sur sa propre voie
si on insiste si on veut toujours tout
contrôler nous fabriquons des adultes
qui seront malheureux et qu'ils seront
incapables de faire leur propre la
propre choix c'est pour ça
je vous le dis cette leur confiance
encouragez les à aller vers ce qu'ils
aiment ils sont vraiment les seuls à
savoir ce qui les anime
et tant pis vraiment c'est pas grave
s'ils n'arrivent pas à identifier
l'adverbe dans la proposition
subordonnés conjonctive
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]